non alors madame Denise Sempé
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues en octobre dernier
conseil et Parlement européen ont
entériné la fin de la vente des
véhicules à moteur thermique dans
l'Union européenne pour 2030 au profit
de véhicule 100% électrique ce choix
politique suscite des interrogations
légitimes à titre d'exemple la
massification de la voiture électrique
entraînera une hausse significative de
la consommation d'électricité en France
or notre consommation électrique à
s'accné pendant 20 ans en dépit des
aléas conjoncturelles par conséquent je
me demande si notre système de
production électrique peut vraiment
monter en puissance nous avons tous
encore en tête les exhortations du
gouvernement à la sobriété pour éviter
coupure et délestages cet hiver cela ne
rassure donc pas sur cette question
alors certes le gouvernement
semble avoir pris la mesure de l'urgence
avec deux projets de loi visant à
accélérer l'un la production de NR et
l'autre les procédures liées à la
construction de nouvelles installations
nucléaires mais les premiers maitrons
sans doute plusieurs années avant de
fonctionner quant au second elles ne
seront jamais prêtes à avant 2030 par
conséquent je voudrais savoir comment le
gouvernement compte-t-il résoudre
l'équation d'une consommation électrique
augmentant plus rapidement que la
production d'électricité ne serait-il
pas pertinent d'envisager d'autres
solutions comme le biogaz qui présente
un intérêt certain pour décarboner la
mobilité des poids lourds je vous
remercie merci madame la ministre
merci madame la présidente madame la
sénatrice Sempé merci pour votre
question vous interrogez gouvernement
sur le risque de notre système
énergétique d'un accroissement de la
consommation d'électricité en France
d'abord une étude que j'imagine vous
connaissez publier en 2019 par RTE a
démontré l'impact de la mobilité
électrique sur la consommation
électrique française
j'ai perdu quatre secondes pardon
pardonnez-moi madame la Présidente
cette étude désolé confirme que le
système électrique français peut
absorber le développement du véhicule
électrique avec pilotage limité de la
recharge la consommation totale
d'électricité des transports individuels
et collectifs
pèserait au plus un dixième de la
consommation d'électricité totale en
France à échéance 2035 c'est moins que
la consommation du chauffage résidentiel
c'est moins que l'augmentation de la
consommation électrique de la France
entre 2000 et 2010
sénateur Babarit tout ceci on va pas y
arriver
je suis désolé
non non
je vais retrouver mon souffle ma voix et
je suis là pour répondre aux questions
pardonnez-moi
je vous remercie
donc c'est moins que la consommation du
chauffage résidentiel c'est moins que
l'augmentation de la consommation
électrique de la France entre 2000 et
2010 par ailleurs la consommation
énergétique additionnelle qui est
nécessaire à l'électrification du parc
pourrait en grande partie être justement
compensé par les gains d'efficacité
énergétique dans les autres secteurs
comme le logement par exemple puisque
nous menons en parallèle comme vous le
savez une vaste politique de rénovation
énergétique par ailleurs le pilotage dit
intelligent de la recharge peut
permettre de lisser les besoins de
consommation pour éviter les pointes de
consommation qui sont gourmandes en
énergie et qui entretiennent le besoin
d'importation ou la nécessaire
production d'énergie fossiles le
développement d'outils intelligents de
recharge sera une des clés de la
soutenabilité des véhicules électriques
et pourrait apporter un élément de
réponse aux besoins grandissant de
flexibilité du réseau électrique
vous questionnez enfin madame la
sénatrice la possibilité d'utiliser le
biogaz pour la mobilité le bilan carbone
du biogaz peut certes concurrencer celui
des véhicules électriques mais l'analyse
du cycle de vie assez limite elle ignore
la disponibilité concrète et les coûts
liés aux technologies or le biogaz a une
disponibilité actuelle et future limitée
et sa charge et sa large distribution
nécessiterait des investissements forts
ces deux contraintes ne permettent pas à
cette heure d'en faire une alternative à
l'électrique pour décarboner les
voitures ou les utilitaires légers c'est
donc pourquoi nous recommandons de
réserver les ressources limitées de
biogaz pour des secteurs qui sont déjà
dépendants du gaz plutôt que de créer
une demande supplémentaire dans un
secteur du transport où il existe des
technologies plus adaptées plus matures
pardonnez-moi
madame Saint-Pée oui simplement madame
la ministre je crois que c'est de
l'utopique de penser que la consommation
électrique n'augmentera pas et que vous
tabelez essentiellement sur les
économies qui seront faites et
deuxièmement le biogaz je ne comprends
pas cette réticence du gouvernement de
ne pas utiliser le biogaz qui est une
ressource présente sur les territoires
je vous remercie merci
même la ministre pas de réponse pour
l'instant
je vais je vais suspendre ensuite une
minute pour vous laisser voilà
je crois pas que RTE soit
connu pour sa propension à l'utopie mais
je comprends vos doutes encore une fois
la bascule elle est majeure et le doute
est et salutaire mais je me permets de
vous renvoyer à cette étude pour ce qui
est du biogaz objection retenue du moins
entendu et je suggère peut-être qu'avec
la ministre de l'Énergie auquel je peux
tout à fait faire un message vous en
discutiez plus profondément je ne suis
peut-être pas aussi spécialiste que vous
madame la sédatrice je vous